yo people we're back hustle hot takes
episode three
you see here proper audio this time
and we've got a new team member alex who
will be making these videos
way better than when me the total
amateur we're editing them okay so this
week on hustle hot takes we'll be
talking about tech any trust
of course all over the news is that the
us government will be grilling the ceos
apple amazon google and facebook the
four horsemen
tim cook jeff bezos sandra bachai and
zuckmasterflex
and the topic will be antitrust and i
want to give these captains of industry
some advice on how to handle this
situation
now to get that advice i went
all the way back to 1998 and found video
footage
of william henry gates aka bill gates
getting grilled
by david boyce a famed lawyer who
actually represented al gore during the
gore versus
bush presidential supreme court case
there's over
10 hours of deposition video on youtube
it is incredible
and i went through all of it to the
dismay of my family
but with that i found some gold and have
five tips here
on how to handle government anti-trade
so the first thing that you need to
establish is that you're a cool cat
you're not gonna let government pressure
and the threat of breaking up a hundred
billion dollar company scare you
so what you see here with william henry
gates aka bill gates
is that he's got this pose going on here
this is the i'm one of the two or three
richest people in the world
pose now i can tell you right now by
doing this
i already feel richer i feel the power
surging through me so as we watch this
clip watch how
calm and collected bill gates is
increasing
i.e share on mac genius
it's tip number one now tip number two
is you need to stall
you don't want them getting to the
hard-hitting questions and one way to do
that one sure-fire way
is you make them define every single
word
along the way of their prosecution all
the questions they have now you'll see
here that mr gates
asked david boyce the lawyer to define
the word definition
this is textbook stalling and frankly
quite genius and perfectly executed
okay so if you define definition for
this
conversation genius then i'll understand
what you mean
define definition so tip number three is
related to the first tip
you know body language nine percent of
communication you need to be calm
collected and cool
and one way you do that obviously is
just to be laughing and kind of
light-hearted
and watch here as mr gates just lets out
a very good twirl and kind of primal
laugh
he's setting the stage and he's telling
the lawyer david voice and the us
government
i'm cool i'm cool okay you can't make me
uncool i'm gonna laugh and have a good
time
so let's watch this
oh my gosh did you so he just like he
let it build up
and we need to rewatch it he let it
build up watch this
all right so tip number four there's the
other coin of the laughing and smiling
sometimes you know you just want to show
complete disdain
and that you don't really care and you
got better things to do
and quite frankly if i was the richest
person in the world i'd probably have
better things to do
than me sitting in this uncomfortable
looking chair getting roasted by david
boyce one of the
greatest prosecutional attorneys of the
20th century right i got better things
to do
so how you do that how do you
communicate that idea
bill gates does it with a rock
okay so the last tip here goes back to
the idea of stalling
and what you want to do and what bill
gates demonstrates here is that
you never want the questions to move
forward
it's always about staying stuck in place
or going backwards
now watch here as mr gates tries to get
david boyce to ask him the previous
question backwards key here backwards
yeah it's sort of different late night
then let me ask the question so that
record is clear question
but sure you don't want to let me answer
the last one or if that's
okay there you go captains of industry
mr cook mr bezos
mr zuckmasterflex mr pachai use these
tools
they're at your disposal and if you the
watcher
learned anything or enjoyed that please
subscribe
leave some comments below and drop a
like thank you very much
okay